Australia has a reputation of being
filled with Wildlife that wants to kill
you
blue ringed octopuses bull sharks and
box jellyfish swim along the coasts
saltwater crocodiles haunt the estuaries
funnel web spiders contain a deadly
neurotoxin while huntsman spiders are
less likely to cause serious illness but
far more likely to terrify humans with
their speed and size
and we've done an entire episode on the
incredibly venomous inland taipan and
its close relatives that live on other
parts of the continent
but occasionally the most unexpected
species can turn violent
if you wander through the grassy fields
of Australia you might come across a
scene like this a kangaroo waiting chest
deep in the water with a look on his
face that says come on in the water's
great
if the kangaroo succeeds in luring its
opponent into the water it will
ferociously drown it by holding its head
underwater until it's no longer putting
up a fight
many dogs and dingoes have met their end
in this way
and in 2022 a man was even killed when
he suffered extensive head injuries
including a broken jaw as he attempted
to rescue his two dogs from a large
kangaroo
these fluffy grass eating hopping
animals who fill the same ecological
niche as deer do in other parts of the
world can also be quite dangerous
only about five people per year seek
medical attention after a kangaroo
encounter and it's rare for kangaroos to
kill someone but they're clearly capable
of it
because fighting for dominance in the
world of kangaroos is common and it's
like the animal form of MMA boxing
kicking grappling are all tools used to
take down their opponent
fight usually starts with one male
smacking another in the face
both of them stand up tall lean their
heads back and start to Grapple each
other with their hands
the next move is the kick which can be a
devastating blow due to their giant
Claws and huge muscles in their legs
a cake like this would be enough to
disembowel a human during the hitting
and kicking the kangaroos try to wrestle
each other to the ground
eventually one will give up and a winner
emerges
watching a kangaroo fight like this
makes you glad to not be a kangaroo
because their strength aggressive
behavior and weird physiology make these
animals a force to be reckoned with
kangaroos wallabies betongs kawacas and
rat kangaroos all belong to the macropod
family a name that means Bigfoot they're
descended from arboreal marsupials who
enjoyed a lush rainforest environment in
Australia about 50 million years ago
as the environment changed to a more
Patchwork forest and then became even
drier and more like a desert the
macropod family exploded into a variety
of forms
small mouse-like marsupials like
potteroos and B tongs descended from one
line while the larger Kangaroos and
wallabies descended from another in fact
there was even a brief period around 15
million years ago when a carnivorous
species of kangaroo hunted other animals
marsupials and placental mammals
diverged from a common ancestor more
than 125 million years ago and the
reproductive strategy of marsupials
evolved to be extremely different from
ours in that time
today there are six species of kangaroos
across Australia and New Guinea and they
all belong to the marsupial family who
are known for carrying their young in
pouches
kangaroos give birth after just a month
of pregnancy and their young are among
the largest and most developed of any
marsupial despite the fact that they're
still blind furless barely able to move
and weigh less than two pounds or less
than one kilogram
once they're born they crawl into their
mother's pouch where they spend another
six months feeding off her milk and
finishing their growth
once they're out of the pouch they
become what's called young at foot and
that's when the Joeys really start
developing the skills that make them
such formidable Fighters and Incredibly
efficient hoppers
based on the fossil record it seems that
hopping as a form of locomotion appeared
about 20 million years ago but it wasn't
until much more recently that the
fastest of the modern species red
kangaroos appeared and it's this largest
of the kangaroos that scientists have
been studying for decades because
hopping is rare among vertebrates it's
used mainly by frogs and small mammals
nothing else anywhere near the size of a
red kangaroo hops yet these marsupials
reach great speeds doing so
in 1973 a group of researchers taught
red kangaroos to hop on a treadmill and
wear a mask while doing so in order to
measure their oxygen consumption
in most mammals the faster they run the
higher the energy costs for the body but
the opposite is true for kangaroos
their energy and oxygen requirements are
High when they start hopping but as they
go faster those aerobic demands don't
change hopping at speeds of 15
kilometers per hour is much less energy
costly for kangaroos than for other
mammals of similar sizes and they can
comfortably hop at speeds of 20 to 25
kilometers per hour for quite some time
if they're being chased by predators and
really need to Sprint they can attain
speeds of 65 to 70 kilometers per hour
which puts them among the fastest land
animals in the world
their speed and Energy Efficiency are
the result of a number of adaptations
first there's the size of their hind
limbs which are twice as long as their
forelimbs these give them a base from
which to Spring off of essentially using
a bipedal form of movement
then there are the tough tendons of
their ankles and knees these elastic
bands store energy in a way that doesn't
rely exclusively on mechanical muscle
movement but their muscles are
impressive too the skeletal muscle mass
of red kangaroos is about 50 of their
total body mass making them among the
buffest of mammals most large mammals
like humans and cows only have 35 to 40
percent of their muscle mass made up of
skeletal muscle and for kangaroos the
majority of that muscle is centered
around their pelvis and hind limbs where
they need to generate the spring for
their hopping
kangaroos also have a high density of
mitochondria in their muscle as well as
a high level of capillary density and
blood volumes basically this means their
muscles are supercharged like those of a
racing horse
lastly their large Tails swing in the
opposite direction of their torso
helping them balance out their weight so
they don't tip forward
all these characteristics allow
kangaroos to outrun most predators and
move across wide distances in search of
food
yet when kangaroos move more slowly
their downright clumsy looking and
surprisingly this slow movement requires
a lot more energy
their walking is called pentropedal
Locomotion referring to five feet since
their tail is used like a fifth leg
because it's more energetically costly
to move this slowly they don't do it as
often it means they have to be a little
more choosy about where they're getting
their food from especially since they
eat almost exclusively grass
as we mentioned earlier kangaroos are
basically the Australian version of deer
herbivores who graze on grasses and live
in large groups called mobs
but there's one major difference between
Kangaroos and other grass eaters
kangaroos aren't ruminants
for animals who feed on grass and leaves
it's difficult for the body to break
down so much fiber
ruminants like cows sheep and deer have
four stomach compartments and will
regurgitate food in order to chew it a
second time a process known as
rumination
kangaroos eat an equally fibrous diet
but their stomach has only two Chambers
and they don't chew their cud in
kangaroos the two parts of the stomach
are the saxophone at the front and the
two perform at the back
food moves along this system almost like
a conveyor belt rather than being
stirred over and over again
because food takes a long time to move
through the digestive system of
ruminants they have to eat in smaller
bursts whereas kangaroos can eat more at
one time
kangaroos spend up to 10 hours a day
feeding and their food is such an
important source of moisture but they
can go days and even weeks without water
as long as they're still eating
another significant difference between
the digestion of kangaroos and ruminants
is how the fermentation process works
in order to extract nutrients from all
those high fiber greens bacteria in
these animals digestive systems help
break down the food
for ruminants the hydrogen gas produced
in this process is converted to methane
by bacteria which the animals then burp
or fart out
methane is a greenhouse gas that's 30
times more potent than carbon dioxide
and 50 to 60 percent of it comes from
the agricultural sector and the
digestion of ruminating animals
since people like eating meat so much
this is a major problem and scientists
have been experimenting with ways to get
the animals burping less dangerous gases
which is what led them to study
kangaroos whose digestive fermentation
process doesn't release nearly as much
methane about 27 the amount of ruminants
there are a couple reasons for this one
is that the food moves more rapidly
through the digestive tract of kangaroos
which washes out some of the bacteria
that might otherwise produce methane
but other research has found that
kangaroos have a different kind of
bacteria in their guts
fermentation always produces hydrogen
gas but instead of bacteria that turn it
to methane kangaroos have bacteria that
turn the gas into acetic acid which AIDS
in muscle growth
which leads us right back to where we
started the Incredible strength of
kangaroos
although different species of kangaroo
grow to be different sizes all of them
are pretty big and male red kangaroos
which are the largest can grow to be
absolutely massive
an adult male can weigh 90 kilograms and
stand over 2 meters tall which makes
them significantly larger than the
average human
and starting from the time they're young
all types of kangaroos put their muscles
to use by learning how to fight early in
life Joey's will play fight usually with
their mothers learning how to move their
limbs around
play fighting continues throughout the
lifespan of a kangaroo with adult males
often engaging in ritualized fights
where the goal isn't really to hurt one
another so much as to hone their skills
even females will play fight though it's
less frequent
when things get more violent though is
when kangaroos are trying to get access
to something like water or mating rights
with females
and scientists have found that different
species have different styles of
fighting
those who are slightly smaller break
contact frequently and are more likely
to kick each other
these kicks can be so damaging that
males have evolved hardened dermal
shields on their bellies to avoid being
disemboweled
for larger species like red kangaroos
the main form of fighting is grappling
with the head neck and shoulders
the goal is to throw down the opponent
and the kangaroos do so by whatever
means necessary
the kangaroos will also occasionally
fight off Predators like dingoes though
they're just as likely to hop away to
avoid being caught
and in some cases as I mentioned before
they'll even head for the closest
watering hole and drown any animal that
gets too close to them in reality this
is a defensive maneuver as it's only
trying to protect itself from attack and
it's a strategy that can backfire if the
water is very shallow or very deep in
those cases the kangaroos don't have as
much of an advantage and can easily be
bitten or drowned themselves
although the kangaroos are jacked mainly
because of their need to fight and flee
the muscles also seem to give them an
advantage with the ladies male kangaroos
will sometimes stand in ways that show
off their muscles to entice females and
prove that they're tough enough to
handle newcomers
but those big muscles come at a cost
adult males are more likely to die
during droughts and other periods of
environmental stress possibly because
their bodies require more energy to
maintain
clearly there are pros and cons to being
super buff but it's a strategy that's
worked well for the kangaroos so far
especially considering the larger ones
are currently less endangered than
smaller species of marsupial
just remember if you do run into them in
the wild it's best to keep your distance
if you're really determined to get up
close and personal with a marsupial it's
probably better to go for a wallaby
if you're watching this video you're
probably drawn to the natural world and
all of its strange creatures the
enormous the intelligent the scary the
weird the buff
you've probably marveled at the
complexity of evolution and been in awe
that the laws of physics could allow for
such a variety of organisms on this
planet at least I know I have and for me
my appreciation of the natural world
skyrockets when I take the time to
understand it the endless struggle
between predators and prey is
fascinating but by understanding
differential equations you can create
mathematical models for different
scenarios to see how an increase of
dingoes for example will affect a local
kangaroo population the shell of a
nautilus looks pretty cool but by
understanding geometry you see that it's
an incredible example of a logarithmic
spiral towering trees flowing Rivers
flowers or heads of broccoli these are
all examples of fractals in nature math
allows us to perceive the patterns and
realities of the universe and
brilliant.org is how I learn all this
math interactively brilliant has
thousands of lessons like foundational
geometry and algebra to Advanced
differential equations and calculus you
can also dive into neural networks data
science or even Advanced physics all of
which help me understand the world we
live in and help me to write these
videos the courses are sometimes
challenging but brilliant doesn't
penalize you or impede your progress
instead they give you an in-depth
explanation to guide you to the right
answer so you can learn from your
mistakes it's easy to learn in this low
pressure environment and most
importantly it's easy to learn by doing
and the way brilliant uses interactivity
in lessons like geometry makes so much
sense the beautiful geometry course lets
you use tiling puzzles and sliding
scales to understand the geometry of
Honeycombs and many other beautiful
patterns you see in the world around you
to try everything brilliant has to offer
free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org real science or click on
the link in the description the first
200 people will get 20 off brilliant's
annual premium subscription and every
sign up immensely helps this channel